now in this figure
we've changed something.
here
Let me show you the old one the previous one.
In the previous one we had the number
of athletes who were doping.
versus those who are not doping
And on the right side we had.
Whether they were positive or negative.
in the second figure, however
Here we have whether they are positive or negative first and
then whether they are doping or not doping.
In other words, we have a regrouped the quantities.
instead of having to find out how many tested
positive
by taking these two numbers and looking at them separately. We
have grouped the positive.
Under one branch and then we know
how many are dropping in our doping.
setting for negative
We take all the negative quantities put them under one branch and then
we divide them into whether they are doping or not doping.
We do this because these are the quantities.
That we would need.
to use the Bayesian formula
In the previous tree, we had to find this out.
You know separately we had to calculate those quantities.
And write them down somewhere. Whereas here they already
factored in.
Since we are concerned about the positive tests.
And whether they're guilty or not.
We're going to look at this branch.
Although of course we can answer similar question.
And look at the lower Branch, but we're not concerned with this quantity in
this example. Just
If they tested a positive.
Are they guilty?
And if they are guilty how what is a probability
that they are?
So, let's see how we can use this quantity.
Now first of all, let's talk about let's remind ourselves
about the Bayesian.
theorem
this is the probability version of the
base theorem.
This is the likelihood version of Base
theorem.
This is what we call specifically the
term on the left.
This is the posterior probability.
This is the posterior likelihood.
Why is this probability and why is this likelihood?
First let me tell you what.
Let me first give you the meaning of odds.
Let me first tell you what odds is and what probability is.